all right today's topic somebody sent me
this video get caught
so i caught a texan some some dude this
morning
didn't want to tell me who it is i said
okay i'll let it go
so this is what she does then she won't
try to
i like which color didn't like put on
call the police
call the police wifey
check what you did tell me look at what
you did
look what you did now
look at this push me i was putting the
hands on me
always putting their hands on me
so y'all see this witness witnessed this
you woke her up you're so loud
look at this
this is what i did with on a daily basis
you got caught texting somebody
you're mad because you got caught
texting me and you see this right here
guys
she broke the tv she broke this tv
she broke this right here
so what i do her laptop broke in
her ipad broken
everything in the house is broken so
she's she comes home
and she breaks my chain she comes home
stop touching me stop touching me
stop touching me no no they need to know
who you are
[Applause]
what are your thoughts there's whole
movies about that [ __ ]
those whole movies about girl king cars
i broke the widows off yonko
there's whole songs about that grammys
and [ __ ] are based on all that
waiting to excel taking out your [ __ ]
and burning your stuff
it's it's like it's in the media it's
like we know we can't hit a woman
but it's in the media in the movies that
the woman they slap
oh these like that's good it brings up
the passion
you understand what i'm saying what are
you talking about it's normal [ __ ]
it's it's okay it's okay
that's all right that's the other side
of it you know what i mean imagine that
we know that in society we can't hit
ladies
right and they're still [ __ ]
that do it
imagine when some [ __ ] is accepted i'm
just putting that out there
just putting that out there we know it's
unacceptable we should
hit anyone and there's still people
women that suffer from abuse when we
know
you look at you you get canceled quick
you beat your wife
right imagine what it's accepted is it
when it's in movies
music it happens we shut the [ __ ] up
about it
we do is it right to shut up about it
no but what can you do what are you
gonna do
i would film too but not to put it
online because then again that's
defamation of character
but i'm taking your ass to jail i'm
throwing the book at you i'm oh you
paying all of this
i know you're not gonna go to jail for
hitting me for breaking up bro you're
not going to jail you're a woman you're
not going that's not your thing that's
not your department
and i don't fear for my life so you're
not going nowhere
but i'm getting my money back
that's that would that would be the only
reason i'm filming and that's it
but what are we watching what is it
what do we have to say about that that
it's bad and crazy yeah
but it happens on both sides i've seen
men acting like that too throwing
ugh human beings is weird show the
ending of that
or she screaming clearly tackled or
whatever
if you flip those genders how do you
think people would respond to that video
i don't even have to respond to that
okay i just want to ask you do you want
to ask i have to respond to that just
asking
we're throwing it out there but nobody's
nobody's going to know oh you know
yeah but he's not and could you
keep your hands to yourself you know
what's most unfortunate about all this
what is the kid crying in the back
mm-hmm you know he catches her doing
shady stuff so she breaks his things and
he breaks her things
but he did say something that that
caught me off guard i'm gonna put that
on him though
this is what she always does this is
what i deal with on a daily basis
he said that look look guys this is what
i deal with on a daily basis
i'm a you you you you're whack the girl
whack let me blame but the dude you're
dealing with this on a daily basis
let me rebut it let me rebut you
you get the wrong woman pregnant you try
to make it work
you're all my answer
don't happens a lot happens a lot
that's a whole other topic in regards to
that's a whole other topic that's a
whole other video
but you know it's it's just unfortunate
you know and i think that's why people
have to be careful who they have kids
with
you know you need to know these things
well before you even think about
bringing a child in this world because
two you know two adults fighting that's
one thing one there's a child in the
room
or in the they're crying and they're
being neglected because y'all are
arguing and screaming and leaving out
that energy which the
child can internalize that's not good
for them so people have to be
responsible it's not enough to just say
i want to stay in this make sure you
pick the right person one and two make
sure both y'all are committed
you guys aren't then don't that's what
it really comes down to
because these people i mean breaking
each other stuff like that
there's no teamwork in that that's
sabotage
that's sabotage i could never deal with
that and and then that
on a daily basis because that's telling
me you're starting to quit
if i try to hold you accountable for
something and you start breaking stuff
you've already quit
there's no coming back from that you i
don't think you can to get to that point
is crazy you can't you can't come back
from that i could never imagine i'm mad
at somebody
let's say you're mad at me all right
we're having like a business dispute and
i break your [ __ ] i break the cam i
break
or i break your [ __ ] you're mad at me
and i break your [ __ ] isn't that crazy
that's a level i couldn't even imagine
getting to i feel like by that point
you're far gone
where you think destruction of property
throwing other people's money away
just complete disregard for their
personal space whoo
that's far and i said i'm throwing the
book at you when i'm getting this money
back
it's not going to happen now it's a
process it takes time by that time i
selling that computer
tv and [ __ ] is that it's complicated
it's complicated you know so
if you guys find yourself in situations
where you're constantly finally this you
need to really strong to reassess
whether or not you should be with this
person
strongly reassess because you risk
hurting the people around you you know
people say stuff like this is why you
don't want to be married to the wrong
person no that's why you don't want to
have
kids with the wrong person that's the
truth
that's the truth marriage is one thing
kids that's a different thing not the
whole other
human being is suffering you know people
say don't stay for the kids i agree
that shouldn't be the sole reason but
god damn some of y'all gotta pick your
partners better
you know that this that that's toxic and
you you that's toxic
that's nefarious you said you're dealing
with this
on a daily basis that was science
you must have been or if not you didn't
take enough time to do your research
but hey maybe i'm wrong maybe there's a
side of this i don't see
and you know who knows like i said
people change sometimes that's happens
too
and the truth is if both of y'all one of
y'all's committed initially or both of
you are and then somebody decides they
want to quit
that happens too trying to drag someone
along the finish line that doesn't want
to keep moving
it's a burden it's like trying to do a
group project and you're the only one
working on it
dude and everybody got all the points
you know dude oh you see
you get resentful too yo real quick real
quick so
it's new once i think it's difficult but
uh but yeah it's a tough one
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below we want to hear
from y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign